Elon, people wanna know what books do you recommend ?
I like biographies in general. Biographies you know got a really interesting read.
What do you learn from them?
Well I think you learn a lot, depending upon whose life you are reading about.
Um, there are lots of lessons in there. I read Isaacson's biography of Jobs which I thought was quite interesting.
And I actually really liked his biography of Benjamin Franklin
Who I would say certainly one of my heroes. He seemed like a really great guy.
Basically I sort of was thinking about this one as a kid.
And trying to find some meaning in life like what's the meaning of life, you know.
And um, I quite sort of sad about it actually when I was a teenager and then I read the hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy.
Which basically said like the thrill and the rope. You know basically universe is the answer and you just need to figure out the questions.
So I think, you know. That is if I can help kind of figure out the questions
Then that I consider that to be meaningful.
Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed this series.
I'd love to know have any of you read the books that Elon recommends. Did you like them or did you not? Leave it in the comments below.
If you want me to continue this series about famous entrepreneurs and the books they're reading,
leave that in the comments below too.
Thank you again for watching. Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.